I'm Gary O'Reilly Chuck nice this is
playing with science
yesterday we return to their expanding
universe that is Twittersphere
and explore the thoughts of the dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson don't forget the last
time we considered his tweets we learnt
there's not a good day to be a chicken
or swimming on Mars in anal and an
Olympic pool it will simultaneously
freeze and boil exactly and boil so if
that's your kind of show we have got you
covered
and of course we've got you covered with
the man the myth the legend the man
himself dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson I didn't
know I was a myth what's that you know I
was a myth well myth it calls ago
you are not indeed you are you're not a
myth I don't my being a myth yeah and I
didn't know I see you are here in
corporeal form so I cannot call you a
myth a poriyal form somebody bought a
word of the day I'm good tomorrow is
obstreperous I'm gonna go with them no
no no you got to get stay in the mood
and say tomorrow if today's corporeal
tomorrow's ethereal yes absolutely
very good there you go feel and Neil is
a man of words he loves words and so on
I appreciate that mainly in such as the
way out less than 140 characters yes it
would be fewer than 140 characters if
you kindly see grammar the grammar is
now abroad itself with grammar in the
house Britt you're supposed to know this
it's supposed to be jealous of your
command of the language slightly on the
grammar and we've allowed you to run
free with it
oh thanks why we are divided by a common
language okay thank you Churchill thank
you
beaches here we go so this is our tweet
show and and we have the the tweet and
chief the tweeter in chief deGrasse
Tyson
you pluck my tweets from the
Twittersphere once yes we do yes this is
a school day for us this is front row
the course you are I hope I remember my
tweets that you pull out okay you got
here so what are we going to do we're
going to we're going to kind of jump
around and just hit whatever sports you
guys put that Neil put on Twitter or and
we will see what they say have okay here
we go
ooh in baseball or maybe you should read
them I can it's your voice so early
maybe one in a hundred tweets if that
often I will present an opinion ooh
and all the tweets may feel like
opinions they're written with passion as
most opinions are right they're actually
just facts
passionately conveyed passionately
factual yes but this one you this one
I'm ready to read is a in opinion you
ready this is opinion okay in baseball
if a pitch hits you on ball four you
should get to advance to second base Wow
serves well because if you're hit by a
pitch you take first base ball four you
take first base if hit by pitch on ball
four you go to second base right because
what you just gave the pitcher was a
free pass at beating somebody say it's
hey what do I got to lose this ball for
i I don't like this guy he's gonna take
a base anyway and let me just pop him
why are you worried that the batter
might intentionally get hit by the ball
right you could do that for any pitch
and why don't you
that's one cuz it's ball four and now
we've introduced the math I think bus by
the time you get to first base there's
an attorney waiting for you to argue the
case against you progressing I'm gonna
say that guys who leaned into a pitch
and take a hit they they got cojones
they got they deserve that base cuz I
believe that ball might be traveling
somewhere around 90 miles an hour and
plus or minus 90 miles an hour it
doesn't have that kind of heat yeah and
that's not his thing maybe you take the
percentages maybe you gauge I don't know
enough about baseball rules to know if
you intentionally go in to the strike
zone with your body
it is that really getting hit by pitch
oh no guys have done that there are guys
who bleed to the strikes that they've
leaned in through some rule no the broad
the ball is slightly with the balls on
the edge yeah okay and so of course it's
a judgement call at that point and so
you lean into the pits because you want
to take that base you guaranteed that
base but if you lean into a strike I
don't think they give you your base no
well if if you lean into what is clearly
a strike I don't think what is the rule
in baseball will you be awarded a base
or will you be called for perhaps
something like interference so it's
interfering because it's head of our
legal team he's right now sourcing a
definitive answer to that question and
as soon as we get it you'll have it I
like the concept of ball four you get
hit you get a second you get two getting
a two basis since you would have gotten
a base anyway forgotten a base anyway so
that I'd say that just my opinion I just
thought if we needed a new rule in
baseball that should work anything live
in this game up far as I'm concerned
what did we get into either JEP and in
Sevilla yes sure so we had catcher which
you guys you will hear this show and
that was kind of cool man but JP JP
Arencibia who is a catcher former
catcher of major-league baseball catcher
gave us some really interesting insights
and little league I was catcher that was
my position really yeah yeah oh you're
nice plus you know our one of our
producers Lindsay he was a catcher I do
know that yes he was indeed a catcher he
was a softball catcher in college so
what and we had Holden Kushner on who's
a host for for tuning on their Major
League Baseball and they were saying
they are looking to really get something
going to get this thing up and
invigorating so I don't know whether
you've struck a little bit of a vein
there a little bit of a golden vein
basically what what what what JP was
saying was that the league is looking
for ways to make the game more excited
and he'd said it in the most diplomatic
way possible because he's a former major
league baseball player because you know
the flip side of that flip side of that
coin is the game is boring right that's
the flip side you know right and it's
not boring to the person who's a purist
it's not boring to the guy who's just
there with that little card that's not
the ball games and they're keeping you
know that that that's a person who loves
or somebody like me who loves a pitching
duel you know at a medium weight because
that too much here's the thing I love
the tension that builds torn am i today
yeah I'm older than both of you okay
long baseball games were two hours that
was a long long baseball games and and
would not be uncommon to have a
90-minute baseball game at most 100
minutes and while holidays they bottom
out of two hours and they typically go
three three and a half right a change
though and to watch because I did this
experiment once okay so back in the
video days where there's like video tape
I said I wonder how long the action of a
full nine inning baseball game oh I'm
with you so you just edit out all the
time stuff nobody's happening right
whole game 15 20 minutes they entire
game your target well you just edit out
everything we're not fluid okay anyway
they're running in from the outfield
that's rich innings the time after the
pitch where so here's what happened in
the old days the batter never left the
batter's box right nowadays every pitch
the batter steps out they hit the cleats
with the bat or there's a reason for up
their hands in the dirt though it's
funny I read Oh
at-bat ritual what didn't used to be
there and all it takes think about it if
it previously took you one minute now it
takes you three minutes at your at-bat
everybody takes three times longer than
mr. bat right that's too bad
but there's a whole lot of psychological
rituals and well that's not original
it's actually it's actually neuroscience
when you see a pitch and that and you
stay in the batter's box you don't walk
away you don't and the and the pitcher
throws you another pitch you will see
the last pitch so your brain and shaking
it off right your
we'll say here it comes again when it's
not so your brain lies to you about the
pitch that you've seen so you walk out
of the batter's box
fresh entry get a fresh entry back in so
that's why they do that okay so you're
serious no I'm serious that's north
there is neuroscience behind that are
you saying that Major League Baseball
studied the neuroscience research papers
yes sure
yeah well according to the Scientific
American article that I read four or
five years ago so yeah there's brain
training in baseball in terms of seeing
the pitch you can probably get into that
but getting getting back to you a little
bit of hatred for baseball or so
slightly hatred using your vocabulary
okay so when you take baseball and you
reduce it down to its action only mhm
you can do that for any team sport any
tennis match soccer game NFL game
baseball isn't alone so when you when
you hang about tennis the time you're
playing versus the time you're not
playing is vastly greater yeah than it
is for baseball or not don't but I'm
saying you have some the highlights you
can play as many tricks as you like with
editing mm-hmm to reduce that down to
say this wasn't a great game whichever
sport it is all I'm saying when I said
the baseball could last 15 or 20 mins
I'm not talking about highlights I'm
telling every single pitch right all
right every single pitch so does this
come with televisions influence into the
sport as well because they're selling
airtime so sure the media guys got into
buying major league franchises didn't
they yes so well what you have is you
have collaborations if that's the right
word between a professional team and a
broadcast network so you have the YES
Network didn't Disney own the Yankees at
one stage I don't know and it's me
Murdoch I'm thinking if they did I would
have heard about it yeah sure I don't
because I'm native of the Bronx I may be
spreading disinformation it seems quite
popular these days all right so now yeah
we asked the question whether
not a batter who leans into a pitch that
is clearly a strike
who does he get the walk and here is
explanations of rule by 6.08
hit by pitch situation one batter takes
his or her position in the batter's box
with their arms extended into the strike
zone batter is hit on the arm by the
pitch while not swinging its ruling dead
ball time okay strike on the batter no
award so it's a strike you were you're
right the bed with that or the batter
does not get right take a base when he
strike it's a strike these he's given a
strike situation to situation to batter
swings and misses the pitch and the
pitch touches the batter ruling dead
ball strike on the batter no award so
the swing outweighs the the ball contact
exactly so you swing and get hit right
you're struck you struck out I'll try to
clean it up by taking a situation 3 what
do you have your situation 3 batter
takes proper position in the batter's
box pitch is inside and the batter makes
no attempt to avoid being touched by the
pitch ruling dead ball in other words he
took the hit just took it
ruling no award so they just get it just
counts as a ball you guys even though
you got hit you have to actually so that
if we get out of the way the pitch so it
looks as though the ruling is this if
you are not if you look like you are
intentionally in any way taking a hit
they're not going to give it to you or
or passively or actively passively or
actively whether you just stand there
and don't get out of the way whether you
lean into it either way you can't you're
you can't take you want you to hit that
bowl down they Wow interesting
interesting
well thank you Garrett for that's the
rule crack research team there however
it still says it's still a pretty cool
and interesting prospect to say well
that may be the process it will find its
way back at Major League Baseball HQ
it's just
offering that's all all right all right
so I'll move on to another tweet please
another baseball tweet please let's
bring it up Neal this is nasty
okay all right careful observation that
was me do it
doing the statistics on this all right
you're full observation reveals that
players and coaches of a three-hour
baseball game Oh spit at least six
gallons saliva onto the field oh my god
oh no what what why why that's number
one why what do you believe shatter
why why why would you spit like that
what I want to know is how do you
measure this the spit okay
the spittle the anatomy of this
calculation yes okay all right so here
you go you ready so I made an assumption
which could be off by a little bit and
so they just scale the answer
appropriately okay that every time you
spit you're spitting one cubic
centimeter of liquid the enemies not
that much not a lot not a lot maybe
those guys are Hawking some loogie
they're Hawk and Luca yeah yeah loogies
right loogie okay so that was first
assumption yeah no here's how you make
the measurement watch the camera focus
on one player and another okay
one out of four times in the five
seconds the cameras on a player the
players of players quitting is it like
you owe me that that was my Aegis thing
no no once the first guy spits up they
all kind of looking at the player the
players aren't looking at
really looking at each other so I could
even though that would be kind of cool
if spitting is contagious that if in
these four or five five-second bits
right a player is always spitting okay
that means every player is spitting once
every 30 seconds okay okay all right
and so once every 30 seconds yes course
of the game so now you have 25 players
now other players not on the field right
players sitting down so you're counting
them as spitting - so of course this
spitting in the dugout just look at him
oh my god I am getting sick okay I think
it's 25 active players and the dugout
that's what you know you got the bullpen
and the dugout and the players on the
field okay so every player spitting but
it's it's really real life just do your
own measurement look at how often the
cameras on a player huh and how often
that any random player is spitting you
get Lukey cam Wilson well it's so cubic
centimeter every 30 seconds 30 seconds
from every player for three hours
oh god hmm and it just it just simply
adds up that's all I'm saying
are you oh my god it's the fact that you
may well have underestimated well so it
could be out so I did I say
approximately but no honestly it's it's
clearly an under estimate based on the
time and you're using one cubic
centimeter right it's like I said that's
not a lot collectively I tried spitting
and I could not spit one cubic
centimeter
chewing other people who don't spit
saliva such as a rod a rod spits the
shells of the nuts shelves of sunflower
seeds so that's not I'd say that still
takes a volume so this mixture would be
like hawk to loogies shells of nuts as
well as just pure saliva you know what I
don't know
I bet I am so hungry right now chewing
tobacco now how many how many games in a
season remain 62 how many teams there's
how many teams are there I have no idea
two teams something like that I don't
know not yes a lot of saliva it's a lot
of yeah it's a lot of spit I had a team
I used to spit because I thought it was
cool right I was in middle school right
and I found myself generating more
saliva for having done so after about a
week of it the more you spit the more
he's more the more you have the more you
have this bit strange you talking about
the spitting and the professional
players
I had a teammate you were so young play
was so nervous you could sit there and
just spit really I can consciously just
but pure nerves I can just hear people
out there right now going it's totally
like gagging so here's so here's my
thing yeah so the good thing about a
simple calculation okay so what I say
six gallons so so if I converted cubic
centimeters to imperial gallons
correctly let's assume I did that
correctly for just for the moment so if
we find out the average spit is a half a
cubic centimeter or two cubic
centimeters then it goes it's three
gallons or it's a lot of it's a
veritable tsunami of spit yes sorry
third loogie cam I think it's an awful
lot more than we ever considered yeah I
think that's the right I say we move
along let's do a Caesar why don't you
read your next one because we only have
less than a minute left in this segment
you pull these out of the Twitterverse
that's right sway what's the next one
here's the next one we go
arretez go ahead hand-stitched balls
rubbing mud leather mitts wooden bats
pine tar baseball a game untouched by
modern materials it's the it's the old
way just saying emphasis baseball we
fear change
no is it better or is it worse well if
changing materials will improve the
performance of the player I think you
should do it absolutely if you go to see
performance you don't go to see the
absence of performance you tell so if a
now I'm told that will pick it up we can
you ran out of time yeah we're out of
time we'll pick it up when we get back
up when we get back ready for it versus
aluminium another thing we got in with
JP Arencibia so we'll take that break
we'll have more baseball thoughts of the
good doctor and we'll tell you what
aluminium is when we welcome back I'm
Gary O'Reilly I'm Chuck now is this is
playing with science we are exploring
the tweets of dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson
and focusing most definitely on the
sport of baseball before the break we
were discussing pointer and stitch balls
wouldn't bets and getting into old
versus new now when we spoke to JP
Arencibia
and we spoke with Charles Luke yes
what's the best material you could have
for a baseball bat and Charles went with
aluminium and absolutely said oh baby
I'm a power hitter give me that aluminum
bat yes yes yes so the aluminum so what
I was told by a say berm attrition of
someone who thinks long and hard and
deep about everything that every bit of
detail in baseball that even baseball
fans would not care about okay just to
put it this on scale that's what he told
me was that in professional baseball and
MLB if the batter's used an aluminum bat
it would kill the pitchers because it
would come off the bat SAS oh right now
okay they barely have enough time to
react to react correct oh really if they
can just get a mitt in front of their
face and not get hit by the ball with an
aluminum bat that time is dropped to
below their reaction limits and you
would basically you would harm so you
would increase the exit velocity to a
point where reaction would not be
possible hard-hit ball right will reach
the pitcher before the pitcher can react
and you can
you will hurt the pitcher no I am all
about this awesome you just made
baseball my favorite sport so you can
use Aluna bat and hit a 400 foot home
run every time and you'd kill the bat
the pitcher for the whole see that's
what I'm paying for this is where I knew
that would God will pay to go see this I
want this so this way so this is kind of
like gladiator based batter's revenge to
the pitcher love it
the batter is revenged on the pitcher
you would only sort of accidentally hit
it back to the pitcher because you don't
have that much control it's gonna say
you would have to be the best first of
all you could do that you would never
hit the pitcher you would just place the
ball out of the mark every single time
right you'd be the greatest home run
hitter ever right that would be like
batter's revenge on the fact that you're
sitting duck in front of a 90 mile an
hour fastball Wow but I'm just saying
that's what he told me and and so I had
no reason to doubt what he said a man
should get a pole as to whether or not
they want to see the picture in danger
or whether they report that evening
tragically another death today in
major-league base knows exactly yeah
don't make it break orbital bone orbital
no that's cool man Wow that's it that's
fascination so that would be alone to
make sense how about some other things
so for example so they use pint art so
that could be sticky surely there's some
artificial stickiness that works better
than pine tar globs now what's that
glove snaps gloves will do it yeah you
know you in fact you can put the
material that the past receivers right
use right material right that gel
material might become genuine the Nike
innovation team he came in and they'd
explored a hole of a surface so your
hand goes up the ball just hits and
sticks to your hand so yes so gloves
help that then you don't need to pine
tar but I it was kind of fun to watch
old time like the Yankee catcher from a
few years back he didn't wear gloves he
just yeah yogi opinion
way back Masada
alright what hit facade no gloves my boy
just there it was in the pine tar and it
was sticky and there he was
fans love him for that I I just thought
it was something classic about that
let's call these woods that need gloves
right so yeah the gloves will improve
your your grip but also if the if the
glove is too spongy then your hand is
not act sure your hand has a give
against the surface of the bat so and
fractions of an inch
make a difference between a pop-up and a
home run right the difference between a
home run and I'm guessing from for a
catcher in his mid the intimacy and feel
that has to come through the hand
through the leather and be able to feel
that they've got total caress on that
ball and they can take it to another
place now science after hours is this
who's glove is due so what they could do
so holding materials aside what they
could easily do as is have a laser
measured strike zone and then you don't
need the umpire and they basically have
it in tennis yes they do you've got to
listen to the the baseball show we do
with JP Arencibia because he talks about
what young book on the umpire gives us a
little peek behind the curtain of what
goes on folding this way what I'm saying
is you could do that yeah and it would
be precise every time hunting a debate
so now but but I don't I don't have a
horse in this race if I can mix sports
okay I don't have a ball in this glove
all right all right two of these I want
one on each hand
so so so here's what you're saying thing
what makes baseball interesting is not
knowing if the umpire is gonna
accurately call the ball or the strike
like the edges of the strike zone and
this creates another dimension of
uncertainty for a sadder right because
the pitcher wants to throw a strike but
if they throw a strike you're more
likely to hit it so they have to throw
something that looks like a strike so
that you try to hit it and you don't get
good good good night wood on the ball
exactly so it's it's it's it is
cat-and-mouse like no other one-on-one
encounter and there is another diamond
awesome yeah well no and that that is a
that's that's very salient what you just
said and then the what JP told us was
that in addition to that yeah there is a
political aspect because when you mouth
off to an umpire mm-hmm then says oh
really okay and what he'll do then is
not give you the cost yeah send you to
the naughty base so yeah don't so so
plus they'll give you I saw umpires give
Jeter a call that they were not given
some other players or just nasty players
that just makes sense I mean come on
he's dreamy Derek Jeter hitting me guys
gorgeous all right here we go
this is physics 101 right here I just
rose it out there laws of physics show
that it takes twice as much energy to
throw a baseball 100 miles an hour then
it does to throw one at 70 miles an hour
interest oh okay this is much energy why
it's so hard how many people throw up on
your violin outrace well right how many
it was like five ever you know I mean
how many people that number is not as
high as you think it would be given how
many people throw 90 miles now here's
the deal I know that that is physics 101
yes but there are a lot of people out
there who don't know why that is so
maybe you should tell
and plus she saved me from saying it so
in in physics once we finally learned
what energy was and characterized it and
how what forms it can take okay that
birth the Industrial Revolution just so
you know how important this is oh so
energy tree and it's your ability to
transform it from one form to another
okay is the foundation of every machine
we've ever built that's it yeah okay so
why do cars work because we take
chemical energy in the fuel and convert
it to mechanical energy which is you
moving down the Pistons going up and
where did the chemical energy come from
it came from living matter uh-huh that
once got its energy from the Sun plant
life that was buried and got converted
into fuel so we have sunlight converting
to chemical energy converting to
mechanical energy that's it and once we
learn this it blew open civilization a
Pitchess of soda pallet ultimately we
are all solar-powered there you go
because even if you eat steak right it's
some cow right now he'd grass what we
had the grass grow it's photosynthesis
we and where does the Sun get its energy
from I'm gonna say wow you got me on
that one
there's thermonuclear fusion I was about
to say the plasma that is so called
burning yeah yeah so we are we are
thermonuclear fusion driven right
ultimately like it you like it very much
gonna get that be like a badge
thermonuclear fusion so this this was
the problem I saw there's a bumper
sticker one of these sort of green
bumper stickers right left-leaning green
bumper stickers it says no nukes no
nukes and the O in the know is the Sun
that's know what you mean but the
physics of this doesn't play right
exactly how do you think the Sun is
making its own damn energy did you like
go buy them and flip them the bird and
go you commie and keep going
bastard you hold them over and then just
give him the 1 2 1 lecture I don't get
angry with people for not knowing as an
educator of course oh yeah
the picture around this yank him out of
the car dragging to the side of the road
and then you give them a lecture 100 and
something so here you go
so energy scales here sales as so one
form of energy is kinetic energy the
energy of being in motion motion okay so
anything in motion has kinetic energy
and there's a formula for that it's
one-half times the mass of the thing
times the velocity of the thing squared
okay
all right we're squaring we're squaring
so baseball at 70 miles an hour
square 70 what do you get you get 490
okay square 100 miles an hour what do
you get sorry 70 squared is 4900 okay I
said that wrong yeah wait 7 times 7 is
49 to 0 so 4900 so put a pin in that
number square 100 miles an hour you get
10,000 10,000 is about twice forth right
490 times right so that's how you get it
so 1 squared is twice what 70 squared is
I could have said 72 or whatever would
get you exactly that would I give you an
exam but who cares so to go from 70 to
100 twice as much power is needed
correct now now I went to one of those
MLB traveling arcades okay you ever been
to one of those where there's a pitching
K yeah yeah it's just fun and there's a
bunch of trucks that they open up and
you're going yes you play it's a great
PR for the MLB right and then a pitching
cage and so I thought let me just let me
throw I'm I'm in the shape guy ok was at
the time yeah I'd strength up speed I
have agility I took the ball and I threw
it as fast as I possibly could it went
like 72 miles an hour that's not a bad
pitch excuse me that
what if a pitcher in MLB throw seven
isn't well you can't play Major League
Baseball now the slow ball speed thing
is you would fool a major league batsman
with that pitch because he's thinking
here comes the heat yeah they don't know
that's all I got so you just square it
and this is why for example it is much
more dangerous to drive who's got you
got a quick calculator here do you scold
you yeah so though if you drive yeah so
if you're driving 50 miles an hour okay
okay right
and square that what do you get mmm-hmm
2,500 okay so what is the square root of
5,000 Oh God mmm that's a good one God
we don't need God for this one yeah I do
because we've got for the really hard
calculations button the square root
button they uh I don't know they don't
have the screen okay you have one that
guy one here man please be patient
listen ease these hosts to the game here
okay so what do we say we said go 50
squared was 2005 we have fought so now
we want 5,000 square root okay and we
get 70 so if you're driving at 70 miles
an hour your car has twice the kinetic
energy then at 50 what it means is if
you are in a head-on collision there's
twice as much energy that has to
dissipate by the time everything stops
moving yeah and that energy goes into
crushing the car making the glass goes
into the sound of the collision then it
goes into crushing the squishy things
that are inside the car itself right
when being unless of course you already
ejected and go through the front
windshield right then you go through the
front windshield at 70 miles an hour
then you'll hit something else at 70
miles an hour where does that kinetic
energy goes if you hit a brick wall
right
a brick wall exactly all that energy
gets put back into your body right and
you look like a Rorschach test against
the wall exactly going back to the
nicest if I've got a guy of six foot
five really long levers hmm I'm on a
mound so I am pitching down horribly his
name is Randy jacks Randy Johnson lost
Jackson is not is gonna be a pitcher
does the link to deliever not then mean
I have less need to upgrade the energy
release a tall guy I've got a longer
lever and I'm bringing it to bear a lot
easier for you to hit a hundred miles an
hour is what you're saying
until we to get that speed with a longer
lever is not do I not need to use less
energy you still have to well so so
here's the thing if you if you pivot at
your shoulder you have a really long arm
yep then if we are both pivoting our
shoulder at the same rate yes but my arm
is longer that ball is moving faster at
the end of that right but you still have
to the ball has a mass yes you have to
stand the constant edger and your arm
has mass so you muscle has to be up so
it's not the same thing happening No so
it's oh so back up yes to arms swinging
at the same angular speed if I have
longer arms I'm throwing the ball faster
than you are but I have to move my arm
as fast as you're moving your arm and it
takes me more energy to do so right oh
cool okay oh that's cool that's right
that was just kind of real rate the ball
and and the weight of my own arm so it's
the same thing as when you have like two
things on a string and you're swinging
them at one string is shorter and the
other string is longer yes yes two
things on the end of the string one is
going to be going faster on the longer
string on the water string but it takes
more energy to keep going from my logic
it would have been the other way round
which is why I asked the question okay
you're gonna bust that myth that's why
we have yet so I don't know how you got
your law
because he said by your logic against
Josie no a fair competition good no but
the good thing about taking physics
classes and that you learn the logic of
the universe and that replace or the
logic of your life well the logic of our
universe right now is that we do have to
take a break do that we are past we ran
over I ran but guess what it was worth
it and so we're gonna take a break and
we'll be right back with more Neil
deGrasse Tyson and his tweets
I'm Gary O'Reilly jackknives we are
honored to have dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson
with us and he's various numerous tweets
and we are sinking our teeth into
baseball
we've chewed on quite a bit be clear I
didn't post these tweets so that you
could use them for this show it's not my
intent we did that without your
permission I just want you know I put
them out there for the four peeps out
there who wanted to see a little bit of
physics and into sports but see in 140
characters or fewer yes or fewer and I
and I tweet a hundred twenty-five
characters so you purposely keep your
tweets at 125 characters that's how I
roll OCD compartment you can't give a
detailed explanation of why your
thoughts have gone there and I think
what we're being what we're trying to do
is give our listeners the the
opportunity to understand what's behind
yeah that okay oh no we're not claiming
them as our own understood can't claim
them as my own when you're not in your
presence did you just a minute ago put
on lip balm I did indeed and I must say
that I defy any man to put on lip balm
and look manly not once have you ever
been in a bar and seen a guy like excuse
me no I'm you know what I'm gonna do I'm
a bust your face right now
hold on one second put on some lip balm
first yeah let's do this
that will never ever happen ok put any
time I see someone using lip balm I must
share with you the fact that the Cassini
mission to Saturn
yeah which will end this year yes okay
it's been going for 12 years I mean this
applies to lip balm but I'm all is oh
yeah okay so the Cassini mission to
Saturn right it was like a three billion
dollar mission over the 12 years
something like that
and Argon's you asked me yeah yeah yeah
so you divide it out what is it per year
yeah it's a few hundred million dollars
per year that's a bargain in the United
States we spend as much money as the
Cassini mission to Saturn on lip balm
whoa look at that so when I see you
putting lip on I want to take it off
your lips and get another machine out to
Saturn
I wondered how that journey was going to
equate to lip balm yes I'm happy that we
yes I think I think Americans should
have soft supple lips so I'm not saying
we should just Americans it's American
we should be an American yeah because
we're the big consumer of lip balms
right men and women so I get that so I
just I I just want people to know what
the cost is and so I'm not I want to
take away your lip balm but just
whatever you spent on lip balm put a
little extra in the piggy bank that's
what we're spending on this mission
that's all the money you've saved on lip
balm all right I'm laughing right now
because in our studio for those of you
who are listening via podcast we are
also we can be found in video form on
Startalk all-access comm and right now
in this video running on a loop putting
goddess a sneaky one yeah sneaky lower
lip I have to say I have never looked
more dainty and delicate so Chuck just
so you don't just don't feel bad what if
you have lip balm with me oh thank god
wait okay good see look at that not even
Neal you're a big guy too you can't do
it you cannot put on lip balm and look
manly it's not really something to do
with pinkies out is it it's not that
alright now let's make out I think we
need to take a break what's the next
trade the man uses three tons of lip
balm - go ahead go ahead sir all right
just just to be clear so the mission was
several hundred million dollars a year
there's like 300 million people living
in the United States
so that's $1 worth of lip balm per year
I have that right and that's an easy
it's a hard calculation exactly easy
calculate it's not a stretch to see how
how you get that number okay so what's
the tweet what do you got here if
baseball reported averages to four
decimal places instead of three then a
300 hitter would be batting 3,000 okay
well that makes sense so I just want to
make it clear to people when they saw is
batting 300 mathematically that's not
what he's batting he's batting point
three zero zero right okay so he's
actually batting 3/10 right exactly so
three out of ten times he gets a hit
gets a hit so basically a 70% is what he
is
you can feel 70% of the time and still
get an awesome player you still get in
the Hall of Fame so it's just by
tradition that we carry an extra two
decimal places beyond the first one so
it technically he's batting 308 of a
thousand ok ok so but you're leaving off
the thousand and if it's just a pure 300
hitter you're batting three lieutenants
any of these would work the same way as
saying you're batting 300
but we don't say they're batting 0.3
that we just don't it's not in the
tradition of the reporting of the game
and it also makes them seem like losers
no it turns out later in the season you
want to carry a 4th decimal because a
single at Bad has a much lower torque on
your
bridge then it does at the beginning of
the season I think about it okay explain
what me I'll tell you these I'll tell
you all right
I've played one game this season I've
had four at-bats okay I happen to get
four hits
oh shoot so what's my batting average
the best what's my batting average man a
thousand sounds of you bet you're
betting one at my dad in one okay now
the next game I'm old for four so now I
have 8 total at-bats with four hits I'm
batting 500 500 it's the next game I'm
over for again all right now back I
still bet 250 250 right no would be no
you'd be batting no point no you're
betting no cuz what do I have
oh no cuz I have 12 hits I mean I have
12 at-bats now four hits okay so no no 4
out of 12 is 4 8 12 right so you go down
to now you're batting 3 3 3 3 3 so
jumping much many more digits early in
the season because the average has fewer
has a smaller base line on which to
calculate it that's yeah ok
at the end of the season your bet a
thousand Tyler 500 times a single at-bat
is touching maybe that last decimal
place that's yeah so you add a fourth
decimal place and then you then use your
back in business watching what you're
doing
cool yeah cool that phrase statistics
and damn lies Oh lies damn lies and
statistics so you can manufacture that
statistic to say whatever really you
want it to say no no 70% of the time
however you want to talk they're both
inaccurate yes what attitude you want to
copyright isn't right yeah it really
it's it's really a marketing thing you
want to present it that's top baseball
should track extraordinary plays that
fielders can bank and then credit
against errors they might later commit
this is another opinion okay I don't
know if I'm following okay you ready
ready
I I'm running after the ball I'm an
outfield I'm right after I do a
shoestring catch and I tumble roll roll
back to my feet and throw the guy out at
second base all right okay that's gonna
make a highlight reel yes it is the next
game I make an error that place should
cancel out the error that's what I'm
gonna have to push back no I want to
bank that extraordinary play no you know
what he doesn't look like that because
you can pay 8 million dollars a great
that shoestring catch should be done
every single game or supposed to be the
absolute creme creme de la creme and so
you're not smart I want a bank account
you want a bank or a bank account the
Golden Rule especially since if you make
a great play you may have prevented a
run yeah oh yeah they call it robbing a
guy of a home run there you go you when
you catch a ball right when it's about
to leave the party can even Stephen
doesn't work like that
you get the goldens of the BRIT sort of
overarching sporting attitude in the
elite sphere is you're only as good as
your last game in this account scroll
that down to you're only as good as your
last play so whatever you did in the
past
baby history we're living in the now
you're thinking nothing for what you did
before because every time you step out
across that white line you have to
reprove your reputation you have to
improve reproof deliver way I like it
that's the Janet Jackson what have you
done for me lately lately all right so
we're almost out of time we're at the
end so anything else where I was
thinking of tweeting this but it
required more thought than then I was
able to give it and so I haven't tweeted
this yet question now okay
spoil okay if you are an outfielder okay
hmm and you always make the highlight
reel for extraordinary catches okay does
that just mean you're slow
yeah I understand that okay
okay cuz here's the deal okay I'm with
you on this one with me I get you
so let me suddenly let me see if I'm
following you correctly so here's the
deal
ball is hit hard to right to right field
okay right center right center that's
even better hard to right center okay
and I take off and I feel I'm the right
field and I'm running I'm Hall acid and
then all of a sudden I lay myself out
and I snag it I hit the ground I bounce
I come up and I hold it up and I'm like
yes and everybody's like you know same
plate
now I'm the center field your center
fielder hard right I am fast as I don't
know what I get there and wait for the
ball okay so you're looking at him
saying he got there late because he's
slow what if he shouldn't be within the
same zip code of this catch and the only
reason he gets there he's that quick
he's cheap so we know in advance right
that he is slow that's all I'm saying
we know he's slow and that's why he
always looks like he's making a great
play here's what complicates it to your
point no so here we go yes yeah master
Britt fellow why do I think that's not
good for me no no no it's it's all said
with affection okay here's here's the
our our closest allies what I think
you're trying to say yes okay that the
slow person has a smaller circumference
a smaller perimeter mm-hmm in which he
can make the play because he doesn't run
very far between the site of the hit
ball and when the ball gets out there is
another point where as the fast person
covers a wider area of the outfield so
their perimeter is
they have a much wider hole slots wider
yes okay and so their coastline gives
them more opportunity to make a
spectacular the guy who's towing trailer
right a good Pro more people yes that's
it right so a good Pro knows their
limitations so if the guy is really fast
he's limitations as you've highlighted
are that much bigger now the guy who
doesn't have the foot spoiler Lauren no
in terms of the space they can guess
basically the guy who's got less speed
knows he's got less speed yet he's been
in the majors X amount he is possibly 10
years there's a reason why what doesn't
happen down at his feet happens between
his ears he will now know the pitch the
better the way the series you say he's
the smarter player he has to be he will
be moving or he just could be lucky and
be on teams where there's a center
fielder who's like I got it it's not all
about speed sometimes the intelligence
and experience of a player will make him
naturally moved before and position
himself to compensate for the lack of
speed which is why the guy's been an
all-star five out of ten years that he's
been in the major leagues doesn't have
this foot speed but he's got something
going on upstairs that's another side of
the coin you might or might not wish to
consider well for the purposes of this
tweet that guy doesn't exist there's no
amount of intelligence that will
compensate from not being fast guides
you wouldn't want a team full of Olympic
sprinters that could do the job but the
guys don't all have the same foot speed
so the guys that can exist without the
foot speakers in the car they've got
something else going up there they know
they're reading they are ahead of the
play I got to tell you something what
you just said about there's no amount of
intelligence that can compensate just
very quickly I a long time ago when I
was in corporate America which ahead on
speed things I'm saying we did this
team-building exercise where you go away
for a weekend once in corporate America
was please let's not go there let the
record sell anyway part of the seminar
the guy when it comes to putting
together a team he says he says to
everybody so when you're putting
together a team let's say we're putting
the other football team what would you
want would you rather have a guy who is
the fastest the most incredible physical
specimen ever or but maybe he's not that
bright or would you rather have a guy
like Rudy remember the movie Rudy a guy
who will give it a hundred and fifty
percent even though that's impossible
but he would do it every single time
give you a hundred and fifty percent
he's completely Rudy the benchwarmer guy
who got to play he's like what guy would
you want on your team and so a bunch of
people put up their hands and said I
want Rudy cuz that guy's like you know
he's got grit he's gonna and I went give
me the stupid give me the stupid fast
dude and he said absolutely you want the
stupid fast guy cuz there's no
accounting for that you cannot make that
up right yeah aren't you gonna teach him
to catch intelligence we can only add to
that sentence dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson
thanks man should I tweet that the
outfielder outfielder I like it I still
don't feel I'm coming out we're out of
this right on that point let's say
goodbye thank you once again for being
our guests here on playing with science
I'm Gary O'Reilly and I'm Chuck nice
you've had the pleasure of dr. Neil
deGrasse Tyson and we look forward to
more come at a pleasure thank you sir
thank you sir
thank you kindly and more tweets I'm
sure from Neil in the future stay tuned
we look forward to your company next
time hey did you like that cool video
huh well how about a bunch of cool
videos all commercial free plus
exclusive original content that you
can't find anyplace else all on Startalk
all-access com